okay gruner let's sit you down right
here and look Christmas
cartoons
pretty part three yeah it's weird
there's actually a lot of these holiday
theme superhero episodes though I've
gotten some of the more obvious ones out
of the way already they's still enough
to do another Christmas video that won't
perform very well maybe you could start
marathoning these every December once
I've built up a bunch of them I either
way they're fun and I like to be festive
so let's dig into some holiday spirit
and rip the Garland intestines and candy
cane Bones from the body of Santa here's
five more superhero
holidays this one's weird because it's
definitely a tie-in with Avengers
Assemble but the title of it is Marvel
Superhero Adventures Frost fight even
though Marvel Superhero Adventures is
like a separate animated show more aimed
at preschool age kids using the 2017
Marvel cartoon designs for the book ends
and a Chibi art style for the shorts
themselves they put that branding on
this movie but it has nothing to do with
that series and I say movie because this
is by far the longest of these specials
clocking in at 85 minutes genuinely it
could have been 20 minutes and it would
have gotten the point across just fine
the story for this one is that Loki
wants to steal the power of Santa Claus
who is a real guy in the Marvel Universe
for nefarious ious purposes of an
unsavory nature I think it's cool to
finally see one of these shows
acknowledge that weird part of Marvel
lore Santa Claus is an actual guy in the
same universe where Frank Castle's
children were shot to pieces in a public
park he's beaten up a burglar and one of
my favorite issues of Spider-Man by
Peter David and Deadpool gave him a
compound fracture in his knee one time
after being hired to kill him after the
elves staged a walk out and ruined
Christmas why does Santa skip good
little boys and girls like Benjamin grim
and Kamala KH every year I know why he
skips Kitty Pride she's got a potty
mouth but the rest I feel like there's a
Darkness there regardless Frost fight
imagines the jolly old Saint is a
product of Asgardian Mythos and calls
him
yoler they treat his magical abilities
as a superpower the same as Thor's
hammer and for some reason Iron Man is
convinced he can't possibly exist
because of the math not lining up for
how Santa does his thing despite hanging
out with a bunch of like Gods and
Monsters but the young rookie Avenger
reptile of Superhero Squad Fame still
believes also my research has showed
that reptile is not in a single other
episode of this entire show what's also
weird about this movie is that despite
using the Avengers Assemble art style it
doesn't have all the same cast members
either Roger Craig Smith is replaced by
Matt Mercer as Captain America this is
weird for me because after watching all
the Marvel anime last year I associate
his voice with Iron Man there's a
rotating group of guys who can all kind
of sound like Robert Downey Jr that just
get picked at random and all of them
sound pretty much the same which is to
say they all remind me of Jarvis
initiate and ball torture protocol
Matt Mercer is actually my favorite Iron
Man voice I kind of wish he would get to
do it more anyway according to this
special Santa may actually be the
fastest Speedster in the Marvel Universe
he's their equivalent to The Flash and
both of them have a habit of of breaking
and entering Frost fight is kind of hard
to sit through the humor is bad time to
make some ice
scream get it it's a play on words and
the animation is so stiff the fight
scenes are kind of toned down for the
younger audience and somehow the whole
thing feels very dry and low energy
there's so much dead air between
characters talking and the sound mixing
is really limp despite being over an
hour long it feels much longer because
there's so much downtime of characters
just sitting there and talking about
stuff but not interesting stuff there's
a b plot of Rocket and Groot from the
Guardians cartoon trying to score a
bounty by taking in Santa but it doesn't
really need to be there the payoff is
that they show up to shoot this ice
giant guy and they brought Mrs Claus I
feel like they're just there because
Guardians movies are popular around this
time and Marvel want to keep them
present for cross
promotion brand Synergy oh God at least
he's not stupid baby Groot remember how
obnoxious and omnipresent that got I
feel like this is one of the most
half-ass phoned in well it's for kids so
who gives a animated specials I've
ever seen I don't recommend this one
this is doodo not after a great start
but maybe taking it back to the Golden
Age of Saturday morning cartoons will
reinvigorate my Christmas
spirit Way Way Back in the 1980s the
king of Saturday morning action cartoons
was the technov Viking badass of Eternia
himself he him along with his twin
sister spin-off she her even though
atoria is a distant alien world in the
center of the universe where magic and
advanced technology coexist they still
know about the concept of Christmas
because he-man's Mom is from Earth go
figure it's better than that stupid ass
life day in Star Wars I suppose happy
life Day pal Prince Adams dumb idiot
comic relief sidekick Orco accidentally
hijacks a spaceship and takes it to
Earth where he learns all about
Christmas from the locals once they
teleport Orco home they realize they NAB
these two Earth kids along with him and
they will have to throw a Christmas
celebration while they wait a few days
to send them back once the teleporter
recharges because of this horrible
inconvenience to Santa Claus having to
go all the way out of his way to aoria
in the center of the universe what the
guys a crazy superpowered monster thing
named horde Prime in list Skeletor and
hordak to ruin Christmas because big
Cosmic beings inside of clouds are
always jerks I know a lot of that
sentence is just gibberish it sounds
like not even the same language I if you
watch this you know who these people are
it's fun watching these two villains
interacting and having a contest to see
who can ruin Christmas harder hey Shira
what's the worst fandom other than
Spider-Man
Swifty despite being half the length of
frost fight the pacing is way better so
much happens in this for 30 minute
special that it's hard to succinctly
summarize all of it without just going
into Cliff Notes but I appreciate that
it feels like you're getting your
money's worth for action and plot and a
little bit of christmy stuff the best
part is that the hero that saves the day
at the end is Skeletor he gets so
overwhelmed by the children's innocent
Christmas joy that he can't help himself
and repeatedly saves their lives from
the other bad guys he's so embarrassed
by acting heroic and kind if he had a
face you just know he'd be blushing this
one's fun and too cute to pass up I do
recommend He-Man and Shira save
Christmas blah blah blah whatever all
right the Christmas spirit is rising
we're so
back oh my God Plastic Man is voiced by
Master Shake from aquatine they show
rules in this easily digestible 11
minute short Green Arrow desperately
tries to impress Batman with a Christmas
party and Plastic Man invites
superpowered Hulk zombie Solomon grunt
for some reason it's short funny and to
the point I like how this show portrays
the Justice League like casual work
friends that just chill when they're not
superheroing kind of like the dynamic
from the Robot Chicken specials just
less animosity and cynicism the show's
also got a really great voice cast hi
Batman I didn't think you were
coming put me down oh I miss Kevin
Conroy I only got to speak to him twice
but he was super nice both times rip
Dark Knight because this Show's episodes
are so quick they sometimes have a hard
time fully developing characters and
conflicts but this one manages to pull
it all together at the end in a
satisfying way that fittingly emphasizes
the spirit of giving and hanging out
with 100-year-old giant muscular zombie
gangsters you think Fred tor's throat
ever hurts after voicing characters like
[Music]
these before he was Dwayne Johnson ser
alcoholic drinks at the premiere of a PG
movie for some reason crypto had his
very own Animated Series where Superman
allows crypto to be adopted by a boy
named Kevin who is the only person on
Earth who can talk to crypto Dr doitt
style I feel weird seeing this show in
such crisp HD widescreen I remember this
exclusively crunched down on my old CRT
TV in the mid 2000 when I was
homeschooling and watched cartoons 11
hours a day after finishing all my
homework and one we've really hit this
strange effect where old stuff just
isn't going to look old anymore the
human eye can't tell the difference
between 1080P in 4k don't you lie to me
this could have come out yesterday for
all I know not
2005 anyway Kev here tries to get a
story book for his little sister for
Christmas but accidentally reads a spell
that transports him into the stories
within the book Krypto the spooky dog
jumanji's in after him and they
encounter various fairy Tal characters
portrayed by Kevin's own family from The
Real World like an oz thing they're
doing an oz thing weirdly these stories
have nothing to do with Christmas nor
does the theme really of this entire
episode he could have just as easily
gotten the book for his sister's
birthday I don't know why this has book
ends about holidays but the whole middle
doesn't tie into that yeah I'm running
out of popular ones of these I've only
got enough to make uh actually two or
three more well I covered crypto this
super dog no one can say I forgot about
it which superhero Christmas thing do
you think I should cover next year that
I haven't already maybe you've got one
in mind that I didn't know about I'm not
sure about Guardians it's not a cartoon
well you know everything in the MCU is
about 80% a cartoon if you know what I'm
saying I don't know I think I could be
convinced if you made a compelling
enough case for it let's end this one on
a low note and go to the Christmas
special from a show set exclusively
during summer vacation it's July
I feel like this episode is the product
of someone in a position of authority at
Cartoon Network telling the Ben 10 staff
hey you should do a Christmas special
this is non-negotiable and then they had
to scramble to figure out how to make it
work despite the whole show taking place
over a single summer you ever think
about how they go on So Many Adventures
in this series that these things need to
be happening once daily maybe like twice
a day I think to make the time timeline
of this show work there can't be a
single day of this road trip where
nothing eventful happens every day has
to be an alien invasion a shape-shifting
doppelganger Venom type bad guy or some
run in with an evil wizard or
unexplained magic curse on this
particularly hot summer day Ben and his
road trip crew family stop off at a
year- round Christmas theme park in the
desert to cool off from the grueling
heat here they find that the park is
under some kind of nearly Century long
curse where the founder has become a
Christmas obsessed Maniac inventing
death traps and turning all the patrons
into evil elves to prepare for a holiday
that never came why why are their eyes
like that I don't like the way they draw
the Eyes Upon seeing his big red shirt
and large belly the villain mistakes
Grandpa Max for a Santa Claus and forces
him to go along with their plan I think
this is a weird case where the cartoon
refuses to acknowledge Santa is real
because Grandpa Max never states that he
is and he seems to think this guy's a
lunatic for believing in Santa's
existence this is a cruel world where
fascist space fairing alien overlords
and assassins exist but the magic of St
Nick does not instead of snapping
Jingles the crazy elf king out of his
delusion they realize the only way to
break the curse is actually just to
humor the poor guy and use Ben's scary
alien to make their Christmas
Dreams Come True by actually delivering
presents all over the world in the
middle of summer this is where the
suspension of disbelief is inexplicably
shattered even if they introduce some
kind of SciFi machine that can quickly
autopilot anywhere on earth now I could
buy that on its own but the slays being
hoisted by Ben is stinkfly and he has to
do all of this in under 10 minutes
before he turns back into a
human come on we can't go this is beyond
Santa delivering to billions of houses
is from DUS Till Dawn at least that's
multiple hours this is going to every
house in the world in under 10 minutes I
don't think even the flash has a feet
like this under his belt when we're
having pointless discussions of power
scaling I think this needs to be
addressed in some way because Ben
Tennison temporarily became the fastest
object in the entire history of the
SpaceTime Continuum without melting
Grandpa Max's face off in that sleigh
behind him yes it's a dumb episode who
cares I know I'm reading too much into
it so the day is saved and because of
this mysterious curse being broken all
the boys and girls in the Christmas
Village Theme Park are magically freed
and it's like the whole Weird elf slave
for 80 years thing never happened
because their friend shows up as an old
man who had a normal life perhaps this
was a magic curse or perhaps this is the
result of Ben moving so quickly that he
accidentally altered the course of
history like in flasho and had a
positive effect of saving the these poor
people from a life of U tied servitude
to a despotic rank and bass fetish fiend
there's also some message about how it's
not the gifts you give on Christmas but
the thought that counts and it's just
all about spending time with loved ones
instead of getting huge presents sure
it's a little shoehorned in and this
whole episode is ill conceived in the
first place but I'm a sucker for that
schaly peace on Earth because it's
December stuff so it filled me with the
sticky hot Christmas Joy I so
desperately wanted to guzzle down not
expecting this video to do any better
than the other ones if you can't tell
but I just enjoy writing them and
sometimes it's not about the views it's
about sending a message Spider-Man this
year has been rough on me like really
rough and I've dealt with some hardships
and trials i' never have before in my
life but at the end of it all I'm still
proud to have my family and friends
around me I spent a lot of time with my
online friends in real life in 2023
which was really cool and I moved into
my own place for the first time ever
because of your generous support by
viewing the videos and backing the
patreon and I get to be with the love of
my life for our own very first Christmas
together as an independent married
couple spider Manchild could never so
from the bottom of my heart thank you to
all my friends family and dedicated
viewers who made this year bearable by
sticking with me let's make 2024 a good
one love to all buy my junk on eBay and
for God's sake yes I'm still working on
the Spider-Man 2 video before you ask
[Music]
go